brian austin greene and his girlfriend
sharna burgess are expecting their first
child together now a source tells e.t
what his ex megan fox thinks about the
news it is what it is
the source notes that megan was a little
surprised but is focused on her own
engagement to rocker machine gun kelly
so she's not overthinking how this new
baby will affect the family dynamic with
her and brian's boys of course the
former couple was married from 2010 to
2021 i just was kind of in love with him
right away and they share three sons
together nine-year-old noah
seven-year-old bodie and five-year-old
journey i've had a kid every other year
since 2012.
and that's just a it's a lot the 35 year
old actress announced her engagement to
mgk last month after more than a year of
dating
[Music]
it was just magical the two met while
filming midnight in the switchgrass back
in march 2020. working with him is
amazing he's so charismatic and he's so
naturally gifted she later starred in
his music video for bloody valentine
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah he's not allowed to have other hoes
in his music video
it's the queen or no one a source
previously told et that brian is happy
for her and the engagement news really
doesn't affect him one way or the other
and now our source says the co-parents
whose divorce was finalized earlier this
month do things for the sake of the kids
and have finally gotten to a point of
peacefulness and respect quote they
balance things well and megan knows she
can't block brian from pursuing his own
happiness and does like sharna and
thinks she's sweet i'm excited for
this time in life and i'm excited that
she's in my life
and uh i
i i think she's amazing my kids love her
it's like it's it's it's a win-win right
now earlier this month the beverly hills
90210 star revealed that he and sharna
are expecting a baby and on wednesday
they revealed it's a boy due in july
brian gushed on instagram sharna i
cannot wait to see you hold your slash
our baby the dancing with the stars alum
also shared the happy news posting this
black and white snap with brian and his
son's hands on her pregnant belly quote
brian i love our family i love that it's
growing and i love you how did we get so
lucky she's great with him she really is
last year brian praised sharna's
relationship with his kids she just
instinctually
sort of knows how to love them and they
feel really safe with her and it and
it's it's an amazing connection that
they have and the lovebirds opened up
about the possibility of expanding the
family one day kids have always been on
the cards for me well 100 they've always
been on the cards for me um
so
you know we'll see what the universe
says will happen
it's just gonna leave that open fast
forward to 2022 and the australian
dancer is pregnant a source tells et
that sharna is embracing this journey
feeling great and focusing on her
well-being as for brian et source says
he is super excited and over the moon
brian thinks sharna is going to be an
awesome mom friends wouldn't be
surprised if an engagement happened soon
too
[Music]